la comunidad internacional responde a
las acciones del régimen iraní las
potencias europeas reaccionaron este
lunes a las nuevas condenas a muerte a
otros tres manifestantes que se suman a
la sentencia de 26 años de prisión
contra el futbolista amir asadani y a
las ejecuciones de dos hombres el último
sábado Francia Reino Unido y Alemania
convocaron a los representantes iraníes
de mayor Rango en sus respectivos países
al respecto se pronunció la ministra de
exteriores alemana Ana Elena barback
hoy di instrucciones para que el
embajador iraní sea convocado a la
oficina de relaciones exteriores una vez
más para dejar inequívocamente Claro que
la brutal represión la opresión y el
terror contra su propia población así
como las dos ejecuciones recientes no
quedarán sin consecuencias un régimen
que asesina a su propia juventud para
intimidar a su población no tiene futuro
del otro lado del Atlántico también hubo
represalias en contra del régimen iraní
el gobierno canadiense comunicó que
suministra asuntos internacionales
Melanie impuso sanciones contra dos
individuos y tres entidades cercanas a
la administración iraní a pesar del
rechazo de los países occidentales en la
chatola Alika meney defendió la postura
del régimen hincazón y que el objetivo
de las personas presentes en los
disturbios no era superar las
debilidades del país sino destruir sus
fortalezas en duda estas acciones son
traición y las instituciones
responsables se ocupan de la traición
con seriedad y Justicia
la dinámica de la justicia iraní ya se
ha cobrado la vida de al menos cuatro
personas en un intento por calmar las
protestas que estallaron en septiembre
de 2022 tras la muerte de maxa a